[Music]
nicholas is in miami florida hi nicholas
how are you
hey hey dr john how you guys doing great
how can we help
uh first i want to say thank you for
taking my call i appreciate it sure
um so
recently separated from the military
march of 2020 not by choice my dad
made a few bad decisions uh
hug around some people that i shouldn't
have and uh ultimately got separated
early
um it wasn't on terrible terms it was
still an honorable discharge but uh
i just couldn't finish uh my contract
so early on in my time in the military i
purchased the vehicle uh just as you do
as
as you know a lot of people do in the
military soon you get that paycheck
so purchase the vehicle for about twenty
two thousand dollars
uh put zero down on it and uh
the payments came up to around 470
around that a month
um i made the payments for about the
first four months or so
and come the fifth month or when the
fifth month
came around i missed the payment and i
just snowballed from there
and i didn't end up paying on the car
for about a year and a half
um and for the better part of the year
and a half
around like a year three months and the
car never got repossessed
um during that entire time wow um
are you still you still have the car no
so it got repoed in um
so i i got the car finally june
of 2019 yeah uh paid for it for about
the first
three to four months so now you have a
repo okay
yeah or sorry not 29 got the car in uh
uh
june of 2018 and they got repo'd in may
of 2020 paid for it for about the first
four months
so um car got repo'd
and um you know they they sell it to
auction and nicholas what's your
question
i i wanted to know what
should i do because i i i owe
i owe the uh about this offered me a
settlement of twenty four hundred
dollars
for the car uh during the time that i
got the car
i also bought a pair of tires uh
and i didn't end up paying on that so uh
i own the tire the tire's about 1200
i got a settlement offer for that as
well for about two hundred fifty dollars
okay so twenty seven hundred dollars
solves your problems
and i have a thousand dollars in credit
card debt okay um
thirty seven hundred dollars problems
what's your income
um so i i just got a job i make
conservatively speaking about fifteen
hundred dollars a month
and as of right now i am a full-time
student
um i was looking at purchasing a
vehicle that was like the main thing i
wanted to purchase a vehicle
this week actually i'm about three
thousand dollars saved
and uh i wanted to get a car um but i
wanted to know
are you getting around now uh i i use my
grandma's car
and and is it an extra car or why is why
are you able to use her car
um well she she doesn't really drive
much you know she's
like she's up 76 she doesn't really
drive at all so she just has
her emergencies really for her but so
how much could you drive it for two more
months
um yeah oh i could but
she i could but it's not
i mean it's not going to inconvenience
her she's not driving it
you just don't want to how old are you
uh
22. ah okay
all right yeah so and jumping into crap
jumping into crap that you can't afford
is caused you pain
right time to stop doing that
making decisions that you know aren't
right has caused you pain man
you know this is not smart so i'm going
to take
2 000 of your 3000 and get rid of
2000 of the 3 700
worth of debt which means i'm going to
get rid of the tire debt
and the credit card debt and then i'm
going to save towards 2400 to settle
that
stupid debt uh with a repo and
um you're going to be done with that in
about a month and a half because you
need to be working like a maniac like
six jobs while you're in school full
time
i want you to have no personal social
life at all
i want you to do nothing but make money
and clean up your dadgum mess
because this is so stressful dude it's
not fun can hear your voice man it's not
fun
you're not it's hard for you to even
think through this clearly
because the stress is so overwhelming am
i wrong
no no no it's driving you nuts you're
not even sleeping good are you
listen you hit it right on the now yeah
i've been there man i've been that
scared and freaked out
and let me just tell you if you will
work like a maniac live on beans and
rice
use 2 000 towards the 3 700
problem that you have and then knock the
2400 out in a month and a half to two
months from now
and then save up and buy you a car for
three thousand dollars
in cash by the end of sep by september
you're going to be debt-free driving a
car that you paid cash for
and working a plan called your education
towards having a great life in the
future
now you got control of your dadgum life
that sounds appealing to me yeah
i i agree my my honestly my plan was
and and there especially hearing what
you just said i know you're gonna
disagree with it i was gonna
i i i was gonna get a car for
around six thousand dollars uh you don't
need
any more debt honey man don't do it dude
this has not been a blessing in your
life
you call me up stressed out not sleeping
because you got debt and repos on
tires and cars and credit cards and no
and no no peace that's why we call our
thing
financial peace two words that don't go
together
you know so please don't do that honey
you do whatever you want to do you're
22. you're grown man you're allowed to
do it it's legal
but that doesn't mean it ain't stupid
don't do it i want you to reverse
engineer the last 24 months of your life
man
and look at the decisions that haven't
worked and don't
voluntarily walk back into them you've
already done it man
taking out a big loan it's probably jeep
it was stupid
and putting big tires on it was stupid
and
you've been given a gift to sell
to settle at the price that you've
you've been asked to settle
it's a gift brother yeah take it you
told somebody
i will pay you and you didn't and
they're offering your way out
do it go see one of the counselors that
you pay for at this college
go see somebody get your head screwed on
straight and don't make stupid decisions
on top of stupid decision you're smarter
than this man
i know you are it's you know ask
yourself what's going to give me peace
a new car payment is not on the list and
doing the same thing that
got you in this mess in the first place
it isn't the journey out take a new road
man
yeah first step to getting out of debt
don't borrow anymore
man big step big step you can do it you
call me back if we can help you anyway
we're here to help you man i've been
right where you are i've been scared
and i've been living in the poop that i
made and that's where you are
and um just you know the trick is don't
don't keep doing it
no and i feel myself getting passionate
because i've been there too man he's in
the house
just like yeah walking around figure
this out sweat in the palm of your hands
yeah
it's just not it's not fun it's not fun
anyway so we feel for you we're not
we're not shamed no we're not picking on
you
two old guys that have been there man
yeah we just um yeah
i love you man i don't want to see you
hurt yeah hold on kelly's going to pick
up i'm going to send you a copy of the
total money makeover thank you for your
service to our country sir